alarm in the streets of russian-backed
separatist controlled donetsk
the siren sounded after the leader of
the self-declared republic announced the
mass evacuation of civilians
as of today february the 18th a mass
centralized evacuation of the population
to the russian federation has been
organized
women children and the elderly are to be
evacuated first
children gathered at evacuation points
lines of cars began heading towards the
russian border
sources in dinettes told al jazeera bus
drivers were ordered to stay and help
the evacuation
ukraine and its western backers have for
days been saying that russia plans a
so-called false flag incident which
could give moscow or the separatists it
supports a pretext to attack russia
calls that a lie
but hours later russian media said this
was a car bombing in donetsk
no casualties were reported but the
target was said to be a top security
official in the breakaway region this is
said to show a center where men can sign
up to join the separatist forces
soon after the announcement by pushing
the leader of the other russian-backed
self-declared republic of lugansk
followed suit
and said all those who can carry a
weapon should be prepared to fight
i call on civilians who are not
mobilized or involved in the maintenance
of infrastructure to leave for russia as
soon as possible
the announcement came after what the
ukrainian government and the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe the osce say was
some of the worst shelling by the
russian-backed separatists in years
the separatists accused the ukrainian
army of the same
ukraine's top military commander said
ukraine had no intention of attacking
the separatist hell territory
i reiterate that the military and
political leadership of ukraine don't
plan and are not conducting offensive
operations in the east the only option
of the occupation of the people and
territory that is acceptable to us is
the political and diplomatic one
villagers close to where the ukrainian
government is in control was surprised
and scared by
we haven't heard the news about the
evacuation on the other side i only
heard about the kindergarten being
shelled yesterday and they say that it
was provocation there has to be an
investigation
of course we are worried we have
children and grandchildren we just want
peace otherwise we will have to leave
this area it must stop we have lived
through this horror for years
the announcement by the leadership of
both the self-declared donetsk and
luganx people's republic of a massive
evacuation on the separatist control
side of the front line has huge
implications for potentially hundreds of
thousands of people living in areas like
these on the ukrainian government
controlled territory despite russia
repeatedly saying it has no intention of
an invasion or military escalation
against ukraine those words are becoming
increasingly hard to believe charles
stratford al jazeera nova norwegian
eastern ukraine